mi piaceva mantenere i trojans
se oggi a grandissima richiesta torniamo
in questo ci avete richiesto i
tantissimi di fare rete skype rumi in
prigioni come potete vedere stiamo già
nella prigione qua però questa prigione
un po diversa perché sono le segrete
infatti vedete è una pressione un po
amica sarà ancora più difficile ma voi
mi raccomando per portarsi fortunato
giuliana tripla su di un bel mi piace
vediamo di dare quante volte morirà se
avete visto gli scorsi più sugli effetti
di cosa sto parlando
ci sono tutti i momenti in cui vita
l'amore visto i video ancora stilista
che ha mandati a seguirmi il nome alife
store esiste ora mettetevi comodi prima
tesi popolo all'inizia musei e così colà
cosa dobbiamo fare
attento ecco vitale che inizia a cadere
già me lo sento che valore 4 bisogna
prendere la rincorsa qui si potesse
saltare da lì è un penso proprio in
questa setta che abbiamo reagito meglio
provare a forse con nell'angolino guarda
bravo in questa eco e toronto signora
merkel e vediamo che dice per una zona
di sei giochi sono harry scappiamo
mentre la guardia sta dormendo quando
vado a salvarlo è tanto o no guardate
quanta lava per terra parini bisogna
soltanto
[Musica]
perché ogni volta che vuoi mi appare
comprare un e mi appare un animale
diverso ora è apparso puoi comprare un
animale zombie ma perché non ricoprire
un animale zombie quando vuoi
i barili si muovono ok io ce l'ho fatta
sono mesi credo che evitare mi ha
superato e non è possibile prevedere che
stiamo più a giulia un po cosa troviamo
questo che allora c'è scritto sembra che
stiano ancora costruendo quest'area stai
attento a non cadere nella laura come
facevamo in grado di saper mi ha
avvisato fate cose è già accaduto vitale
3 4 3 ma quali sono i pezzi che cadono
finora nuova non aver niente da tergo
mento finora tranne vitale forse più
difficile dell'altra l'altro era una
prigione moderna questa che è successo a
ecco vitale da lucera sarà spesso un po
allora s'è scritto queste trappole
sembrano mortali stai attento ai tuoi
movimenti stai attento poi a non essere
fatto in pezzetti qua i pezzettini
ci sono delle fate così stai attento
facile facile facile ok ok
piano piano ci sono quasi e sui da
lesbica ancora più difficile però c'era
un bottone
io continuo andare sembra di essere in
un castello tipo che bello quando mi
salvatevi salpare ma ci sono dei bar che
è successo ho aperto dei bauli ma dentro
c'era tipo un uomo che mi ha fatto
morire
quindi se pensano ad aprire i bauli non
avrei bauli non c'è un tesoro dentro che
piano piano
io sono qui dietro sfiorato io sono
passato non ci posso credere non ce l'ho
fatta
spetta adesso adesso sono sicuro che
vitali si dimenticherà rimasta arabi
riaprirà scuola finalmente allora questa
volta non ha pronto un bayern baule
baule a prevenirlo aperti tutti è però
l'unico che si apre è questo ma non c'è
una chiave dentro e ti amo farlo tu non
ci fossi una chiave per gli altri loro
parti tutti allora vuol dire che sono
tutte dalle trappole poiché dice dice
che bisogna scritto che c'è bisogno di
una chiave per aprire la porta ma che
arrivano di questi bolidi a una gara ma
sto ma abbiamo avuto provavi 1
dai dobbiamo trovare questa chiave
vediamo che si sta cosa qua da qualche
parte prego scusi la prima non c'è
niente che detto dietro il baule trovato
questa ragazza l'ha trovata ma non male
stiamo giocando con altre persone sono
rimaste bloccate ma ha aperto la porta a
me eccola la presa guarda stava grazie
grazie
ok salviamo ci sono queste cose strane
che noi le trappole attendono non
caderci dentro vai piano guarda
facilissimo vediamo se vuoi passare
invece viene spiato sono delle trappole
giganti e wow ma guardate che bel
castello sono troppo questa prigione
bellissima mano piano piano ma tu sei
riuscito a portarsi anche sabato adesso
mi metto qui a vedere come viene
spizzicata e mi faccio deve rifare
salviamo ok quelle che insieme alla
semplice che può forse non lo sa mandare
giù attento a salta su queste travi a ok
poco vitale quanto tempo ci metterà a
cadere ma che guarda sono bravissimo
ancora vivo sono atterrato sono
atterrato nel cosa giusto così salvato
per un pelo
[Musica]
ecco c'è l'uscita di credo che se non è
casuale
beh io vado avanti ecco vitale laggiù
vediamo se ce la fa cadere ma certo che
ce la faccio cresce a morire ma perché
c'è il pulsante per salvare allora c'è
scritto attenzione e stento delle
trappole in lontananza cioè qua vicino
quali saranno le trappole sicuramente
non bisogna cadere questo bisogna
abbinare il piano chiaro più strazianti
a quando si salta quindi ci vogliono
spiaccicare sicuramente
ho capito perché vado io mi piaceva
mangime massei casa sotto non troppi
peccati solo tu spiaccico anche ombre e
quindi stai superate io uomo questa
skype room fantasma
ho capito che puoi cadere da lì basta
che non salti troppo forte allora tu
rimani lì all angolino così mi puoi
vedere
guarda guarda mi sa che meglio se vai
prima su e poi vado io perché se lo
guardai ma spiaccicare funzionato vabbè
io vado senza vita è così almeno posso
farcela
bye bye aiuto
sta arrivando vitale sono stato io canto
mio ok allora vado prima io ok ma no
almeno tempo se ci sono i primi dieci
cari vabbè allora aspetto qui ti basta
andare piano piano piano si sa cosa ci
fai li vediamo vitale come viene
spiaccicato non escape the prison escape
di pale hai visto che bravo insinui
tavolo per non dare a salvare prima
quella che cosa il quale non forno con
boni
ok oggi abbiamo già stata di 47 si
appisola la sua ottava dove sei
sono qui sono qui non ti fidi di me o no
come faccio a passare adesso perché la
cattiva che si è attivata tu non
schiacciare questa mattonella nostro che
è il mio quando sei passata così
l'attivo tiago a carbone dunque a me
ricorda indiana jones
e già che c'è la palla di pietra che non
segue lui deve scappare se preferite tra
no forse involontariamente best api che
mi dispiace per te ma mi sono trascinato
quale non mi ha fatto niente anche se
tutto questo non finita aiuto che come
questo devo entrare qua che stai facendo
non distruggere tutto ciò mi ha
teletrasportato vabbè io salvo ok è
visto che ho pure aiutato e tu subito
pronte a dire che sono stato io a farmi
fuori con quella palla di pietra è un è
arrivato anche evitare allora sei
iscritto
siamo arrivati a un tempio molto strano
usa il tappeto della velocità per
correre più veloce ve lo ricordate
sì questo per divertente pronti a io no
questo sarà difficilissimo meno detto no
non ci credo solo così fatta volare
no no vabbè così difficile corriamo
barnier ha salvato qua ci sono dei
cavalieri giganti così mi ci mettono un
po harry potter
adoro troppo e niente vita nel frattempo
che aspettiamo vitale
passiamo qua aiuto con la lava e viola o
la piano piano piano piano farcela ciao
cavaliere che non si muova questo
cavaliere altrimenti alla fine lo avrai
voglia di esplorare questi mi sarebbe
ancora saltandoli diano abbassare il pro
il ponte trova una manopola
invitiamo circolo qua bastato il ponte
il ponte non c'è qualcuna che purtroppo
devo rifare gettato il capo perché sono
state ad aspettare sul ponte che io vado
stupito il ponte è così non cado brighi
ma ci passavo c'è un bravo c'è un bravo
sul capitello guarda invece mi
ricordasse reg
tutti film wow ma io adoro troppo i
cartelli fantasia d'oro ha detto devi
saltare per un pelo dove stare caduta
quella di quanto siamo in alto piano
piano
wow ma bellissimo quel drago anche un po
harry potter è un po soffrire un po
harry potter infatti il castello sembra
un po
wow ok salviamo non ci credo che evitare
più avanti di me come file il libricino
arrivo qui c'è un pulsante verde con una
leva che sono io che ho premuto e che
succede tipo un ascensore
wow wow stavo salendo su eva giusti si è
incastrato che è successo è successo lì
sprofondando l'ex quello cosa sta
succedendo sta andando molto lento
questa sensore non è un ascensore
moderno forse dovevamo salire uno alla
volta troppo attento a sapere perché ora
marina stati uniti ma che se l'abbiamo
fatta dice penso che questo sia il
lavoro di un drago è stato il bravo a
mettere questa lava o no io ti odio
questi io voglio sempre fatti
ok l'ultimo sa cosa fare
yes sopra lo scoprirai che cosa se la
soprani il drive nantes aiuto chiuso
bisogna fare scritto non riusciremo a
passare oltre al drago a meno che non
entriamo dentro il drago dobbiamo
entrare in crisi rai che vuol dire nel
proprio pazzo folle come cosa che mi
raccomando ragazzi studiate l'inglese
sapete in permanente per l'urbano perché
utilizzi per tutta la vita
non solo perché una bellissima lingua ma
anche perché così capirete tutti via
studiatevi black watch v fa pensavo che
il dente mi uccidesse ma ma dovevo del
drago essere una bocca del drago d'oro
dice sembra che siamo dentro il drago
ricordati di saltare per riuscire ad
atterrare bene
salviamo tra la cultura guarda queste
sono le cose che ho mangiato il drago
dei testi aiuto dei foto dal piano qua
vai piano qua ci sono dei testi non so
di che aiuto alla fine di ogni tipo noi
diamo il vuoto anche se a volte se ne
dimentichi però cerchiamo di dare questi
tempi un voto da 1 a 10 per ora che se
skype room e bellissimo davvero
bellissima dove siamo adesso perché
tutto è tutto cioè di me so che cos'è
forse questo è un drago di fuoco e di
ghiaccio entrambi si stai attenta che
qui diventa più difficile
aiuto ma non ci sono anche io non sono
molto neanche una volta attento ma
bisogna in questo sempre difficile e
applaude promuovo la rincorsa
bisogna prendere la rincorsa più si va
avanti più diventa difficile questo
aiuto
ora qua c'è la nostra amata moglie era o
il trucco per questa imposta di qua e
saltare in diagonale e pare anche più di
un salto una staccionata
se vuoi farcela anche cubitale
spiaccicata aiuto io devo saltare qua
sotto
è così pronti a saltare ma siamo siamo
riusciti a uscire dal drago non solo da
dove siamo spie non rimbalzano sono qui
non so perché mi sono rimbalzato un paio
di mollo vediamo cosa dice dice che
questa scala ci porterà fuori da questa
prigione
ora però il momento di una lunga
camminata verso casa forse non è ancora
finita l'escape non vediamo ora io sto
salendo infatti è così ti avvisa che
bello che ben sta sempre da caro al
castello uomo si è bellissimo ma io
adoro questo schifo io non voglio capire
a casa in un europa ok se davvero questo
qui se l'è meritato in 10 come voto
interno casa troviamo dentro il castello
dobbiamo attivare una leva dai pronta
letta noi stessi vediamo se faremo di
nuovo la leva che succede arriva perché
non sto capito
uffa però 6 bloccando la sensi
adesso loro un pò così vediamo tutti e
due va bene ma devo dire che bisogna
andare uno alla volta è così come la
mettiamo quest'altro si aspetta adesso
in questa bellissima i prof
credo che qui però dobbiamo salutare
ok siamo ancora dentro il castello
cantelmo d'oro
se c'è un contratto per salvare ma io
voglio un po ammirare il panorama pura
queste montagne quanto sono appunti qui
c'è il traghetto posso portarlo a casa
questi bravi ragazzi anche la luna là
sopra adoro ma anche per il panorama
l'atmosfera il troppo
ok e costruiamo un altro castello si è
scritto sì ce l'abbiamo fatta scritto
che ora dobbiamo trovare il badge che
sarebbe il medaglione segreto ciao luca
abbiamo finito prendiamo il medaglione
in cui abbiamo vinto momento ecco un
altro ea meno male che volevo dire che
la prima volta che finiscono escape
indietro sospetta possiamo trovare il
medaglione segreto alberi non è segreto
vediamo con il talk un il mega salto
wow io voglio andare a esplorare il
cartello lucano trasformativo sono
arrivato a tiboni nel giardino del
castello sabato di forse muoio quindi
proposta di rotta arrivo è il signor
elio mi sono spiaccicato bene lo abbiamo
il castello volevo vedere il bravo
bene purtroppo non riusciamo mai a
trovare questi medaglioni segreti fateci
sapere se voi avete trovato siamo mai
trovati noi non ci riusciamo mai non
riusciamo a capire dove li nascondono
come arrivarci poi esistono perche li
avete trovati che voto date a queste
skype room da una 10 un leader sceglie
10 per gente è stata bellissima ma la
risorse roma che sembra che stride trovo
dentro un fans che ora vi lasciamo a
salire su cui cliccare per vedere
inoltre altri visioni cade su quella che
preferite
buona visione ciao